ليس بالسهل تحقيق النجاح في السوشيال
ميديا فالمنصات مليئه بالرياضيين
والطيارين والمجازفين والطباقين والخبازين
والرقاصين فلا يمكن تحقيق شهره
اذا لم تاتي بالجديد المثير
يوتيوبر امريكي عمره 29 عاما يحب الطيران
والقفز المظلي والمغامرات وهذه السوالف
يصوروا رحلاته مجازفاته دائما لديه قناه
على يوتيوب يتابعها حوالي 140 الف متابع
حلوين المهم لديه هذه الطائره
طائره يعني مجنحه مروحيه من طراز تايلور
كرافت ملاها بالكاميرات للمقدمه والجناحين
والمقصوره وترى بها في سماء كاليفورنيا
على ارتفاع الفي قدم من لديه الوقت ليشاهد
رحله طيران
فقط في سماء كاليفورنيا امر عادي مجرد
بياخه لكن كيف تكون الوثاره
اذا ما تعطلت الطائره في السماء شاهدوا
طبعا بقيه الفيديو يوثق تحطم الطائره
واجيكم كان عالقا في غابه مع جروح دراما
يعني شاهدوا
طبعا يصور كل هذه التفاصيل
حقيقه الفيديو ليس كما صورها فالمقطع نشر
منذ سنه تقريبا وبما انه مثير فقد شاهده
اربعه ملايين شخص هذه الماده هذا اكثر
فيديو تمت مشاهدته على قناته او في حياته
طائره تعطلت ونجا بمعجزه ثم تبين من
التحقيقات انه كان يكذب فطائره لم تتعطل
انما اختلق القصه للحصول على المشاهدات
اخذ الادله عن السلطات من موقعي حطام
الطائره رفع الفيديو بعد شهر من الحادثه
تعليقاتكم على مغامره جيكوب كانت كما يلي
متعب سلطان يقول متعب الان تاكدت بان
الشهره مرض يصعب شفائه وهذا مثال حي لذلك
لا يوجد احد يخرج من طائرته في الجو يدعي
عطلها الا شخص يعاني من مرض عقلي البحار
قال لك ممكن الطياره تطيح فوق شيء سيادي
او بشر او الموضوع فيه سجن ومصيبه كبيره
عليه فعلا ومن الشهره ما قتل عابر انا
عجزت اجمع مبلغ ايفون جديد وهذا يدمر
طائره
يقول يا حليل مشاهير نائله بغوا اثاره
تزاعل مع زوجته ولا طلع اشاعه
سلطان يقول لك اصلا في اجراءات في حاله
انه المحرك طفى وهو لم يلتزم فيها
ما راح يرحمونه طبعا لن يرحمه احد
في ابريل 2022 الغت هيئه الطيران
الفيدراليه رخصه طيران جيكوب فاعترف بانه
عمل على هذه الخدعه للحصول على المال
واعترفها باعاقه التحقيقات الفيدراليه هذه
التهمه يصل حكمها الى الحبس 20 عاما